prix tous les phénomènes dont vous devez
vous méfier ajoute hélas trop souffrir
ou le psy militantisme à votre liste
en gros c'est une technique d' influence
quand des entreprises privées ou des
groupes corporatiste créé de toutes
pièces mouvement citoyen à des fins
commerciales c'est ce que constate le
chercheur celle janvie bits
montrez-nous dunois certains exemples
concrets qui vont nous aider à
comprendre comment ça peut se manifester
ce phénomène alors un des exemples
marquants de ces dernières années où ces
dernières décennies
c'est le cas de philip morris qui en
1993 ou à 93 a créé l'alliance nationale
des fumeurs donc cette association
prétendument de citoyens qui défendent
le les droits des fumeurs étaient en
fait créé de toutes pièces par
l'entreprise de cigarettes et leur
objectif c'était en fait contrer les
études scientifiques mais sinon je pense
au canada notamment l'entreprise bell
qui a dû payer un million de dollars
parce qu'ils ont demandé à leurs
employés
le maître des commentaires positifs pour
ses produits en utilisant des fourneaux
extrêmement problématique système vous
l'évoquez il ya deux dimensions à cette
problématique là ce trotteur fing dans
la sphère politique et aussi dans la
sphère commerciale exactement où d'un
point de vue commercial en général on
essaye soit de vanter ses produits
on est quasiment dont de la publicité
mensongère ou alors en fait on essaye de
décrédibiliser les produits de
concurrents samsung ne vois là a utilisé
cette stratégie là pour remettre les
concurrents en difficulté
et puis d'un autre côté il ya cette
stratégie astroturf inc est utilisé à
des fins politiques ou là l'objectif
c'était influencer les citoyens en
période électorale ou alors d'influencer
directement les politiciens lorsqu'il
met en place de nouvelles lois
il ya tous ces cas où des mouvements
citoyens réel qui existe réellement qui
sont automatiques sont noyautées par des
éléments de das trotter fing exactement
dans l'encart d'actualité raison avec
l'attak de souleymane sy par les
américains en iran il ya notamment une
approche diffère
sion du hashtag iranienne des tests sur
les mêmes et la question qui se pose est
ce que ce sont vraiment des iraniens qui
postent sur peter ses messages ou alors
est-ce que c'est piloté par les
américains pour essayer de créer un
sentiment de justice et légitimité de
leur action
au final c'est une certaine humilité du
message entre l'as trotter et le cloud
légitimes aura ni comment on fait pour
savoir pour détecter à ce site un
cadastre auteurs fing je me dois d'être
mission extrêmement difficile dans le
temps il était facile de voir sur
twitter que l'on avait les
sollicitations de comptes sans photo de
profil avec des pseudonymes qui était
composé uniquement de chiffres et de
lettres aléatoirement et donc il était
évident que c'est contre là étaient des
robots maintenant c'est bien plus
compliqué notamment blanche peut
mentionner notre ferme et roll qu'est ce
que c'est ce sont des personnes réelles
qui sont derrière leur ordinateur et qui
sont payés pour envoyer des commentaires
sur un certains sujets et donc quand on
a un message qui peut paraître
suspicieux et bien on peut essayer de le
copier coller dans un moteur de
recherche ou sur twitter et voir s'il ya
énormément de messages qui sont
similaires et là ça met la puce à
l'oreille aux plaisirs tient ce qui
aurait peut-être un cadastre auteurs
chine est ce que par exemple l'élection
récente de boris johnson a aussi est un
cas d'école en matière de structure fine
c'est assez fascinant parce que pendant
on va regarder la page facebook de boris
johnson lors de son élection en tant que
premier ministre il y avait un nombre
incalculable de messages qui était
extrêmement similaires qui mentionnait
tous à monsieur protein dans le sponsor
n 103 sans doute stratégie en
communication qui est passé par là pour
essayer de montrer qu'en fait il y avait
un soutien populaire à cette élection et
dans le cadre du président plus
globalement la structure fine à jouer un
énorme rôle est donc quand je regarde
dans l'année à venir notamment les
élections aux états unis je me dis que
cette élection également se jouer sur
leurs réseaux sociaux et qu'il faudra
extrêmement vigilant des messages qui
sont répandues sur ce média
la montréalaise cherry lane simoneau
dirige un groupe de patients la société
de la leucémie myéloïde chronique une
forme rare de cancer dont elle est
atteinte depuis près de 20 ans récemment
elle a été approchée par une compagnie
pharmaceutique dans ce qui a toutes les
allures de cas classique d'astro de fait
la structure fine le psy militantisme en
français vous l'avez vécu de près que
c'est arrivé quand on a fait notre
organisation canada
nous avons travaillé beaucoup en temps
avec les compagnies pharmaceutiques 1 2
les compagnies et voulait absolument un
camp contre les produits générés on a la
preuve que les médicaments et les mêmes
choses donc la compagnie pharmaceutique
aurait donc à exercer des pressions sur
vous et votre organisme
oui pour parer contre les médicaments
régénérer oui il est refusé
vous avez refusé absolument cette
compagnie est allé chercher un patient
qui voulait absolument faire un essai
facile de trouver parce qu'il paie le
voyage partout d'un monde en voyageant
premier coin on est comme des movistar
est ce que c'est un cas isolé dans le
secteur de la santé selon le
gouvernement fédéral danone ont annoncé
qu'ils veuillent film était un système
de phonak un nom du mois 1/2 la chaux ue
le verso parmi les compagnies
pharmaceutiques sont pas d'accord avec
ça donc c'est sûr que ils sont entrés en
qu'un travailler avec mes groupes de
patients qui prennent la côte est de la
compagnie pharmaceutique ce pour que la
boucle par la voix la pression populaire
le gouvernement renonce à sa volonté
d'exercer un plus grand contrôle sur les
prix dévissent grayssas qui veut mais
gouvernement fédéral ils vont faire un
tout qui besoin de faire parce qu'il
sait que que très cher pour les
canadiennes pour pays pour les
médicaments innovateurs une somme de
l'aube une en quelque sorte le ce
militantisme sauf que c'est pas encadré
mais les compagnies pharmaceutiques sont
représentés par un organisation de
lobbying mais aussi travail au niveau
des
les groupes de patients il ya aucune
réglementation qui existe ici au canada
qui oblige les groupes de patients au
nom de ces quelle compagnie ou quelle
façon qu'ils ont des fonds pour faire
leur organisation
est-ce que jugé que le phénomène du site
militantisme de la structure est bien
connue des canadiens je pense pas si
vous n'avez pas vraiment grand besoin
d'être oignies c'est pas quelque chose
que vous connaissez